Bara a quitté le Texas pour rejoindre
ses proches à Toronto ce Noël elle en
est à sa troisième tentative la tempête
hivernale a causé l'annulation de
nombreux trajets de VIA Rail tous les
trains de Toronto à Ottawa et de Toronto
à Montréal était annulé le 25 décembre
il faut voyager pas pratique pour les
voyageurs qui peinent arriver à
destination
ça fait vraiment pitié hier je suis je
suis parti pour Montréal on a pris le
bus comme tous les autres mais on est on
était bloqué à au niveau des cas
seulement pendant au moins une affaire
de 6 heures d'État parce que les
restaurants tu as plein de demandes puis
avec des personnes qui couchaient dans
les voitures devant la situation la
messe de kasumine n'avait d'autre choix
que de déclarer l'état d'urgence ce qui
lui entre autres permis d'ouvrir des
centres communautaires plein de manger
ça le monde pouvait manger on va c'est à
tous les matelas et ici c'était les
maintenant
les enfants étaient couchés sur ça un
Noël inattendu mais en belle compagnie
c'est un peu triste quand ils ont à
partir parce que le monde est tellement
heureux sentir comme une communauté ici
oui le groupe est très très
amical on a eu qui ont été scrutés on a
eu de la bouffe de l'abonnement bouffe
ça comme un petit rayon de Noël mais
avec une nouvelle famille comme qui
disent l'esprit de Noël est alors
mon mari
est maintenu question de permettre à la
municipalité de garder ses centres
communautaires ouverts et de se munir
des ressources nécessaires pour se
relever de la tempête ici Rebecca quad
Radio-Canada kasuman